a drug used as a tranquilizer now
helping some people with their mental
health Las Vegas is a clinic that
specializes in a specific type of
therapy to help those with mental health
and physical fatigue 8 news now reporter
Madison Kimbrough spoke to those at Las
Vegas ketamine and has the story
what many people think of
now become an essential way to treat
Mental Health concerns we're talking
about intravenous ketamine and treatment
can take place in rooms just like this
for me personally ketamine has saved my
life Soraya Fisher co-owner of Las Vegas
ketamine in the Northwest Valley suffers
from a variety of mental health
disorders and says she now has her life
back thanks to this drug something
fellow patient Kyle who has been coming
for a month now can agree with I heard
about ketamine therapy through numerous
Outlets I first heard about them like
I'm not taking something that's a rave
drug to get myself better or something
like that and then you start talking to
people and going like no you really need
to take a look at this this
veteran-owned business which opened a
year and a half ago is what's known as a
ketamine infusion Clinic co-owner Adam
Fisher shares with 8 news now just how
much of a need there was to have it here
in the valley there wasn't much
accessibility here in fact we've been
driving up to St George to do treatments
and while ketamine is a controlled
substance and can only legally be
administered through a doctor there has
been a boom of these clinics opening up
across the country and Dr Bennett the
anesthesiologist at the clinic believes
there are more benef benefits involved
in the way their Clinic operates I know
exactly what's getting into their system
when it's administered intravenously and
I can really adjust it and tailor it to
every patient we're doing over 100
diffusions here a month stating with the
other methods like ketamine nasal spray
and oral lozenges it can be difficult to
know how much is actually getting
administered into a person's system and
owner sharing with me that because of
the boom they're now looking to possibly
expand in the near future reporting here
in the Northwest Valley Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now